so hi so this is a bit of
the follow on Dan talk we will talk
about more powerful SEC classes than
decision
diagrams um I would like to start by a
quick recapitulation of what was in
dance talk even though it was
just before but I will re rephrase it a
bit with other words and give you
another view of that mainly using um
probabilistic databases
uh we'll talk quickly about provance and
compilation again and we will Define
this intention extension problem that is
the problem that I mention then I will
show to you how to we could solve the
problem for a specific class of UC clues
that was conjecture to not be
doable and then uh at the end of the
talk I will present a general nice
conjecture that has nothing to do about
databases nothing to do about queries
nothing to do about uh knowledge
compilation and that's I think it's
really interesting so if you fall asleep
during the first two parts I will try to
wake you up and to see the nice
conjecture okay
so one of the under underlying
motivation of what Dan presented to us
is probabilistic databases so what the
the idea of a probabilistic database is
that you want to represent data that is
uncertain that can be probalistic and
one of the simplest ways of doing that
is to use um what's called topple
independent
database so what is a tole independent
database it's just a regular
database but for each topple you have a
proy value that anot the tole that
represent the pro that tole is true or
false and so this represents uh probity
Distribution on the sub databases of the
database where for instance this
database here where we remove the first
and the third tople its probity is just
the product of the ones that are here
and one minus the probity of the ones
that that disappeared so every tole is
independent
okay and now when you have a Boolean
query like this one there are two people
who like the same person you can write
it in first you want and you can one
Define the probity that the this
independent database satisfies the query
to be where just the sum of all subset
of the database that satisfy the query
of the probity of that subset so it's
really just some kind of w in model
counting that you're doing okay um so uh
and so if you want to compute it
directly like this of course it's not
going to be efficient because you have
an exponential number of s database but
sometimes you can do something smarter
for instance for this one you can say
what the probity that this quer is true
is one minus the probity that the query
is false the probity that the query is
false is the probity that no two people
like Bob
okay and what is the probability that no
two people like Bob it's the sum of
nobody likes Bob here or only Alice
likes Bob or only Bob likes Bob or only
John likes Bob so you can compute this
like if you had a long a bigger database
you could do the same thing for every
individual on the left uh on the right
column and then you could just multiply
all of these things because these are
independent events and so you can you
can see that this query you can comput
is Pro in polinomial
time so this this problem we call that
pro pro query evaluation problem so we
fixed the Boolean query and the input is
independent database as before and the
output is probity that the database
satisfies the query so uh regarding Dan
talk it was essentially the same problem
that he presented to us it's just that
in his talk he considered that all
possible uh top are in the in the
database so he had variables x i g k and
so on for every possible tole here we
consider that some topples might not be
here which amounts to just setting to
zero toles that do not occur so really
the same problem but this one is more
maybe motivated by a practice practical
point of
view and soan uh told us that he show
the dichotomy with NES DV
on the complexity of this problem for
unions of conjunctive query so this is a
data data complexity result the query is
fixed and they have a syntactical
Criterion on the query that says that
either this PR is in polinomial time and
then they call the query safe or the
problem is untractable nam sharpy hard
and they call the query unsafe okay I
mentioned that briefly but the algorithm
to algorithm to solve the pr for a safe
query it uses essentially three rules
okay the first rule is the independence
rule that the probity of conjunction is
the product of the of the events when
the events are independent yeah that's
what we used in the previous Slide the
negation rule which say that the
probability of the negation of an event
is just one minus probity of the event
and also this more
powerful other rule inclusion exclusion
which is we can express it like that
probity of a big disjunction is the sum
of the probity of the single events
minus the sum of all conjunction of two
events plus three events and so on okay
so inclusion exclusion so this is what
the three rules that the algorithm
use so I'm going to recap a bit on Pro
on this provenance thing which is what
Dan called the grounding okay so the
provance of a query of a boan query uh
on so this should be a big D and not an
I on the database
it is a Boolean function with whose
variables are the topples or the fact of
the database and that evaluates to true
for valuation of the database if and
only if the the the corresponding sub
database that it selects satisfies the
the query
okay and there will be an example next
slide but because this is a Boolean
function you can represent it in many
possible ways you can represent them in
as Boolean form
binary decision diagrams as boan
circuits we will
see so let's see a small example so this
was the example from the first slide so
two there there there exist two people
who like the same person so what could
be the prevalence of this query on that
database we can represent it as a
Boolean formula if we want we could say
why to to for this query to be satisfied
we have to either have Alice and Bob
like liking Bob or and John like Bob or
Bob and John like mob because this is an
expression of the provence of this we
could also represent it as a Boolean
circuit this way I'm doing a slightly
different computation and doing a case
disjunction uh we say that well either
Alice does not like Bob and then one of
Bob sorry and then Bob and John has have
to like Bob or Alice likes Bob and then
Bob or John have to like bom so this is
in these guys this is just a disjunction
of Bob or John like Bob but it is
written like that for a reason that will
be clear in next slides
okay and so what is NI about about this
prance thing is that it is well suited
for probility evaluation so the nice
thing that we have is that the probility
that the database satisfies the query is
exactly the probity that this
prent circuit or expression of formula
evales to true so this is what then
called The White model counting that I
just call a probity evaluation
here and so thanks to this equation we
know that if we can compute in
polinomial time the provenance of a quer
database in a formalism from knowledge
compilation that allows
po probability computation then we can
solve for in po okay
and we saw in Dan that we could use free
or other decision diagrams we could s
use data mytic and decomposable circuit
didn't Define them but I will do it in
the next
slide and so uh in Dan install we saw
that the safe uqs for which this is
possible are the for with ob dis are the
one that are inversion freeze obds okay
and the question is open for more
General
formalism so I olizee if this recap was
too long because yeah was just the prev
talk okay so what about deterministic
and decomposable circuit we write DDS so
first what is DD
yes size is the size of the domain and
here you have your input size size of
non Zer so are those
equivalent uh I don't think they make a
difference so in then the input is n and
the underlying assumption is that in the
database you have all possible toles of
domain of of size n so you have all
these all these
variables uh when you have the database
as an input we can always consider that
the database is full and that gives you
all the possible
variables so that's just a different way
of looking at the same uh same thing
thing um so a bu circuit uh when we look
at an unate we call that unate
decomposable if any to input gate depend
on dis joint set of variables so the
point is that the events that they
represent are
independent and or gate is deterministic
if uh for any two input Gates they
represent mutually exclusive uh events
meaning that there is no valuation of
the input that uh makes the two children
evaluate to True at the same
time and the circuit is deterministic C
if alls are decomposable or alls are
deterministic okay why is that an
interesting class because we can solve
protic computation on that class how do
we do that if we want to obtain the
prity of so circuit we just replace Ade
by time because the events are
independent plus G or gate by plus
because m is exclusive and negation get
by one minus it always works and that's
so you evaluate bottom up as you do on
an arithmetic
circuit and so this comput somehow this
represent computation of a probability
that you use three rules again again the
independence rule that we saw before the
negation rule again that we saw before
and also this instead of the inclusion
exclusion rule we now have the digion
event rule let's say that probity of a
disjunction is the sum of the probity of
the events when they are uh
joint uh so an example of a
deterministic decomposable circuit is
this one so let's look at it so this or
gate we want to check that it is
deterministic meaning that it's not
possible to evaluate to True its two
children at the same time and here it's
clear why because you cannot have that
Alice likes Bob and that Alice doesn't
like Bob at the same time
okay this endgate is decomposable
because on the left part we depend on
facts Bob and John liking Bob and on the
right part Alis liking Bob okay and you
can check that the other onates are is
are decomposable also so this is a
deterministic decomposable
c so the problem that is uh the most
General problem that is open for this uh
class of circuit is uh if you take a
safe ucq can you compute in poal time
it's provance or dat base as the
deterministic decomposable
circuit um in other word can we replace
this inclusion exclusion rule by the
disjunction rule in this set of three
rules that we are
using why do we want to do this uh
because in general we want to go through
knowledge compilation when we can
because it's a good idea it's more it's
a more modular approach and sometimes it
gives you more um more uh problems that
can solve uh but in general this is the
main idea of knowledge compilation that
you show one task and can be done on a
certain formalism from knowledge
compilation and then whenever you have a
problem you don't have to design
specific algorithm from scratch for the
task you can just so that there is a
compilation to this knowledge
compilation for manism and then you have
the the thing we wanted for free okay so
that's the whole plan of the knowledge
compation so how much
time so now we'll talk about um yeah the
problem whether it's possible for dnf is
also open right but yes for dnf it's
also open imply this one but it would
imply yeah I mean a positive answer for
DF would imply this one negative we
don't know yeah but so I'm using um
interesting to this one because for
protic computation we don't need the nnf
part
you can have negation everywhere and it
works so we will focus on a class of uqs
that will be denoted H that are defined
next SL I think these are the same qu
that D talk us about so will not be
confused and for this class it had been
conjectured that for some safe queries
in that class we cannot compute the
perance of this qu in poal time as the
teristic de composable circuits and
there is a reason while people thought
that first it's because these are kind
of the simplest queries for which the
delis and soci algorithm needs to use
inclusion exclusion and we didn't see
how to get rid of that and simulate it
with a Boolean
circuit and the second reason is because
of these lower bonds that we know that
for some of these queries it is indeed
true that we cannot compile them as
circuits as structured deterministic
decomposable nnf so it's a another kind
of circuit a bit more restricting than
just deterministic decomposable and for
what then presented to us decision dnfs
okay so if we want to compute
deterministic decomposable circuit for
these queries we know that the
determinism cannot be too restricted it
cannot be a decision determinism and we
know that the the the shape of the
circuit cannot be too restricted it
cannot be structured I'm not going to
Define what it means but so this means
that there is very little leg room to
make to make this
work and so the main result of this part
of the talk is that for every safe Cur
in this class we can in compute
this DET composable circuit for the
pr so what are the H queries so it's the
queries that then showed us so we have a
relational um signature with a and t of
R1 and we have a bunch of predicates of
R2 and we're going to Define queries h k
i for I between Z and
K so HK Z is this one so I'm going to
use the existential quantifier version
here so it's this one where a and Si I
you have hkii and then you have hkk that
ends up with using T
okay and I'm going to denot Define HK to
be the set of uqs that you can form
using Boolean combination of these of
these queries so you you take any
Boolean combination that don't use
negation of this queries you can always
rewrite that as a ucq okay and this is
HK and then H is just the union of these
HK queries
okay so I'm going to try to sketch the
the proof at a high level probably this
is going only to be interesting people
who are aware of the problem but uh yeah
going back to the previous I'm just a
bit confused with this H class does it
have a key inversion or or not again so
HK is a class of queries H query in that
class it can have an inversion or not if
it does not have an inversion then we
know it has a polinomial size obds if it
has an inversion it does not have
polinomial size OBS but we have seen
with that told that maybe you can still
Compu this probity with inclusion
exclusion and then it's not clear if you
can do it with deterministic
decomposable circuits and so you're
going to show that all queries in HK
have a d they're all tractable and they
all have a d I'm going to show that all
queries that are in HK and that are safe
have yeah
DD the one that are hard we are not
interestes in in
them okay so first step is to represent
such a query so I'm going to denote by K
this this
set and we represent a quy like this so
here we this is the has diagram of the
Boolean latis of two of 22k so the top
so this is the this is the the diagram
the top node is just the set K the
bottom node is just empty set and here
we have all possible subsets of of K I
forgot to put this on the slides but get
it now when I pick a node in this uh
thing it is a subset of K and I'm going
to say that the it is associated with a
subquery that we write q v and what is
this subquery it is uh it's saying that
you have to satisfy all the query hkl
for l in v and you have to not satisfy
all the queries hkl for L not in v so
it's telling you exactly what ques uh
you you
satisfy and now so in particular what's
interesting about this is that if you
take all these possible all these
subqueries for two distinct nodes they
are disjoint because they are telling
you just exactly what are the queries
that you satisfy and so if you take any
database it will satisfy exactly one of
these sub
queries now the query itself Q is going
to be the disjunction of a particular
set of such subqueries so this the query
q is just the disjunction of all the
queries represented by the orange nodes
okay so if Q is a if Q is a q is a is a
ucq then actually this set of orange
node should should be upward closed set
of the Boolean lce but here I'm not uh
WR um drawing this because we will need
to pass through queries that are not uqs
okay so this is the first step of the
proof the first uh the second step is uh
to explain an in gradient of the proof
so this is a this can be obtained by
result from Robert think and Dan
alteru uh it says that if you take just
the query that is simply the two orange
adjacent nodes then for this query you
can compute in polinomial time
deterministic de ciruit for their
prevalence and actually you can even
compute
obdds using the same techniques that Dan
showed us so so this is a query that
that can have negations but actually it
is inverse and free in a sense again
that makes sense and that and then you
can build obdds and obds are in
particular deterministic decomposable
circuits okay I'm not to dig going to D
dig into to how we compute this circuit
but So the plan is that we will use this
uh pair queries as basic building blocks
to to build the
circuit and now what is the idea we will
start from the query que so with lots of
orange nodes okay and we will uncolor
the this graph and we will use two uh
operations the first operation is we
will uncolor two uh adjacent nodes that
were colored and we can also color two
adjacent nodes Weare not colored and the
goal is that we go from the query with
old orange nodes that represent the
query to the Boolean laes where no node
is colored that represent just fals for
which we can have a a
bu and I will explain how at the same
time that we play this game we compute
this deterministic decomposable circuit
for for the
query so how does UNC coloring work
imagine you have your query it's the
disjunction of the subqueries
represented by the orange node and you
uncolor this set of this paare you end
up with this query q Prime and assume
that recursively you are able to compute
a data mytic decomposable circuit for
this query here what do you do to
compute circuit for this query well you
said the prence of this query q is the
prence of the query q prime or the
provenance of this pair that we just
remove removed okay this one will
compute recursively this one we use the
result by think and alter to compute an
obdd or second and what's interesting is
that this or is is deterministic because
all all small queries here they are
mutually mutually exclusive right so
this is a deterministic or that is not
just a decision or on a variable but
something more
complicated okay
and then you continue with c and the
second rule is coloring so here it's a
bit more subtle so this is a trick that
is due to he broke I think and uh so the
idea is that instead of looking at the
query itself you you look at the
negation and you say what is the set of
white nodes it's the so here we color
this this pair the white nodes are well
the pair that we just color or the white
nodes in the Cur Cube Prime that you
obtain after having colored this this
thing
so so if you do if you do this you you
continue doing this for Q Prime and then
you continue you build the circuit and
at the end you will reach the empty uh
buan lce so where all nodes are
uncolored and you will have build
d uh so what's left to explain is uh how
how do we do this how do we go from the
graph with colon no to the empty graph
why is it the case that we can do it so
if we look at this query we can say oh
so I can uncolor this one good okay
uncolor it then you can uncolor this one
good uncolor it and then it looks like
we are stuck but the good thing is that
I have shown that if you if such a query
is safe then okay so this graph is is
The Bu so it's actually a bipartite
graph okay and if such a Cy is safe then
so sorry A C is safe if only if the two
partition of that bipar graph contain
the same number of color nodes so this
is the Criterion of Del and but you have
to work a bit to to to show that this is
equivalent and and so because this is
true we can always find two nodes two
color nodes in the two different
partitions on a path between them that
uses only nodes that are not colored and
then what can you do you color the first
two nodes uh on the on the path you
uncolor the the the these two you
continue you color these two you color
this
two and now you have get rid of these
two even though they were at fire and
you can do the same for the the all the
remaining things because because of this
you color you in color in color and the
circuit okay so that was the this
specific result for this specific class
of uh ciruits and know I have maybe I
don't know 10 minutes uh and I want to
present to you this cool
conjecture uh that does not talk about
databases know compilation or anything
it's just about sets uh so you should
like uh so so this is part of ongoing
work with Anan Lis
thenu okay
so you take a finite family of finite
sets S1 to
SN that are let's say per is
incomparable it's not so important but
let's do say this to simplify for
instance this set of finite
sets any set of fin set you you
want you define its inter section lce
what is that you put your um set family
here on top you do all possible
intersection of of any subset of them so
this one interseting this one is a this
one intered this one is set and so on
and you add a top element here just to
to to make it look
nice now you define um what's called we
call a mish function so it's not
actually the original mobus function
it's a slightly modified modus function
for our purposes so it will assign
integer for every node of this ltis in
the following way on the top node you
put
one and then on an internal node it will
be minus the sum of the mumus function
of I prime for all the I prime that are
strictly larger than uh than you so if
you look at this one it's it's minus the
one that are larger is this one so it's
just minus one so
same here we look at this one the one
that are higher as this this so it's
oneus oneus minus one there is a minus
so re reverse so we get a one okay and
so on here you can check that it's
actually zero why
not yes the right M function this uh
yes yes but usually M functions has two
inputs and I'm specifying it to the yeah
but yes this is the
correct and so what's interesting about
this function so here I'm not inventing
anything it's only thing that are known
is that these coefficient they give you
the coefficients of the terms that you
obtain when you do inclusion exclusion
and you regroup the terms
okay so you you we can show that the
size of the Union of the SI of this
family is the sum of uh the weighted sum
of the size of all intersection in that
in that ltis for I that is not the top
element waed by this Muse value of the
set
I so that's
just combinator that you can find books
and I'm going to Define so in particular
if mu of the ltis on intersection is
zero then the it will not this term will
not appear in the summation
okay it it cancels out and know I Define
the non- conselling intersection of this
set family to be all the intersections
in this thing that are not top okay such
that the Muse value is not zero so here
it will be just this intermediate all of
the intermediate
not I'm going to define a small things
so for two set and that are disjoint we
Define the dejoint Union as just the
union of the set we just put a small
bullet symbol here to emphasize that the
set are dis jointed and also we Define
subset complement s set minus t only
when T is included in s okay
and now when we have a set family Big T
we Define bullet of Big T to be the
smallest set of the smallest set family
that you can form by using the set in t
itself and you can do dis Union like
this and subset subset
complement that's a
definition and the conjecture is that if
you take any finite familiar finite set
like before
then you can express the union of all
the sets in this weird algebra here
where you can use only D non subset
complement but you are only allowed to
use the non conselling intersections of
this set family the thing that we defin
before I'm going to show a few like
three small examples to make it
clear so for this set family it was this
one S1 S2 S3
S4 uh here we can the the non-
concealing intersection we have we can
use is the one that are not not zero so
it's all these things and we want to
express the set a b c d using all the
all these it's really easy we could do
is just a union dint un b d
c like this this isession so the
conjecture is true for this particular
set
family that was easy because actually
the only thing we we had to avoid
which was this guy was the empty set and
empty set can never help you to achieve
anything so yeah let's look at a
slightly more complicated example so
it's the same lace but with a slightly
different set
family so this is again an intersection
lce the zero the muus value is the same
as before and here the zero that we want
to avoid it's not empty set it's a and
now we want to obtain the set a b c d f
g
h s using d sub complement of these
these guys wait and you can do it like
this for instance so you can take
acdg you do a subset complement with AC
this is a low because AC is included in
a CDG right you obtain DG then you can
do the same with this one and this one
you obtain BF then you same this one and
this one you CP and then you can a H and
then you do a dejoint union of
everything this is all disjoint and you
obain the set that you
wanted of course it's not always so
small you have bigger laes like this so
it's a more complicated lates you still
have one Zer and you can do again one
such uh tree okay we have a more
stronger conjecture where we conjecture
that we we can always do this with an
expression that looks like this so left
linear tree uh we don't know the status
of that conjecture
either uh that's all I wanted to
say so Su we have SE a proof that we can
build in polinomial time deterministic
circuit for the query class H that then
show to us um we have showed a general
conjecture about intersection latices of
General set
families uh we for this conjecture we
have tried to find a quter example of
course by boot force and no example so
far we have some partial result about
that so we know lots of small things uh
we have a small pos positive result for
reformulation of that conjecture that we
don't see yet how to extend we are
working on this and I think it's a
really cool problem that uh we've been
working on this for a few years now and
we are a bit stuck so if you have ideas
feel free to to try your your own
proof
thanks
questions does the power
uh the power of inclusion exclusion
comes only from cancellation not from
you know like the way I'm thinking about
in case of counting not just cancell but
you can also have small numbers you can
comp so the the power of inclusion
excent that the Del algorithm use is
really the fact that you can avoid the
the terms that consel because the point
is that sometimes these terms that
consel they are they represent sharply
hard
queries uh and you don't want to compute
them and so it turns out that magically
they canel and so they they can they can
this but there is no I don't think you
use anything about like the values being
small or large or yeah as long as you
have something that is not zero you are
happy if you are zero you want to to
avoid it so it's really about the zeros
of the
function as as a compliment to this
answer I think your results imply that
if you have a query where
there
thanks it's it's a compliment to your
question if we have a query where there
are no Zer in the ltis in the latice
then we can get DDS by this kind of
methods yes so if there are no zeros at
all in the M function of the
intersection ltis we can always get an
expression like this uh and it's not too
hard to to show the problem is really
when you have zeros and here we have
only one zero in this example and we
kind of see how to handle that in some
particular cases but in general you can
have many zeros in the ltis and place
arbitarily and
we yeah is there a query for which
there's a decision
D I
should so is there ay for which there's
separation in the HK family for example
where you can always do this but there
is the FB
uh yes the I think the Cy called q9 it
has an invers well it has an inversion
it has no obdds and I think even it has
no fbds I'm not sure but maybe can
confirm the q9 C it has no
fbds none of none of them have fbds as
as long as they depend on all the
components they f is exponentially large
right and so some of them have DDS and
so when this conjecture is proven true
is that immediate that they all have D
yes if so if this General conjecture
about set is true then this implies the
conjecture on ucq and and stuff nice
thing is that you don't need to talk
about queries and
yeah other questions otherwise thanks
again
[Applause]
and
see